so when you're in the relationship I get
why people say oh we were just in it and
it was happening and I didn't listen to
anybody else because I am I am a firm
believer that if I'm with you and you're
with me we should only listen to each
other because we are the ones in the
relationship no one else is in it it's
just us so I'm curious though don't you
think you would have seen it sooner had
you listened to other people I would
have seen it sooner if I had educated
myself better
that like I I can take full
responsibility and say there were
certain things that I did not know when
I entered that relationship there are
things that now I know after being out
of the relationship and so for me it's
it's growth as a human being it's like
sometimes you you do you have to grow
you have to go through certain
situations to understand exactly what it
is so
I would say
because the reason why I would say no
because even my I'm a stubborn
individual I know that about myself is